effectif la finance toujours mais en
france avec ce plan pour sécuriser les
transactions par carte bancaire sur
internet transactions qui ont représenté
en 2001 1 milliard 524 millions d'euros
soit 10 milliards de francs croissance
de 250 % par rapport à l'année 2000 mais
pour les experts la peur du piratage
reste un frein important au
développement du commerce en ligne
d'où l'intérêt de cette nouvelle méthode
que nous présente françois beaudonnet et
mathieu dreujou cette carte a tout d'une
vraie et pourtant elle est virtuelle le
temps d'acheter sur internet une caisse
de vin par exemple ces seize chiffres ne
sont déjà plus réutilisables seule
condition télécharger un logiciel sur le
site de votre banque
c'est lui qui crée un numéro valable
pour un seul achat et après le numéro
pourra plus jamais être utilisés ni par
mois mais ni par quelqu'un d'autre s'il
est si les récupérer frauduleusement par
quelqu'un d'autre
principal avantage de cette carte
virtuelle acheter sur la toile sans
jamais révéler le numéro de votre vraie
carte bancaire et sans précaution
supplémentaire de la part du vendeur
commerçants lui-même n'a rien à faire ou
que le service fonctionne ce qui veut
dire aussi du côté du client dès qu'il a
le service il a la possibilité
d'utiliser partout sur internet pour
acheter en sur des sites français sur
des sites étrangers peu importe
absolument partout un système qui ne
devrait rien changer pour les 5 millions
d'internautes qui règle déjà leurs
achats en ligne
mais c'est aux autres qu'ils adressent
ceux qui préféraient pas donner leur
numéro de carte bleue et qui paient par
cheikh bâ ce live on a sans doute payé
par carte bleue
et puis enfin tout ce qu'ils
n'achetaient pas bas cela ils vont y
vont se dire tir bas c'est ce qui c'est
j'ai confiance une confiance mise à mal
par l'explosion de la fraude sur
internet x 5 l'an dernier en cause les
numéros de cartes bancaires récupérées
sur les factures est bien recréer sur
des sites facile d'accès et face à ces
deux fraudes la la carte virtuelle ne
peut rien c'est un coup marketing avant
tout puisque ça répond uniquement à une
crainte un peu irrationnel des
consommateurs faut savoir que la
probabilité que vous fassiez pirater
votre numéro de carte en ligne est
extrêmement faibles coûts marketing ou
vrai progrès pour la sécurité
dès demain les clients de la société
générale seront les premiers à tester ce
service moyennant 50 centimes d'euros
d'ici la fin de l'année trois autres
banques devraient suivre